COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some security experts
with their function times.
Will we crack the code?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Mega Ultra VPN is a
personal security group
working to help companies manage
their cryptokeys in the cloud.
Recently, part of their
system was moved over
to Google Cloud
Functions in order
to reduce operational
complexity.
They reached out after
their initial port
as they were seeing less than
ideal response times for Google
Cloud Functions,
and not to mention
a high number of instances.
To figure out what was going on,
we deconstructed the codebase
and ran a few
different V8 profiles
to figure out where the most
CPU intensive areas were.
To no one's surprise,
our security company
was spending the
majority of their API
calls sitting in
crypto functions
that were computing hash
keys for various data
that was coming in.
Now, traditionally, I'd
want to dig into the code
and see where we can
optimize the CPU cycles,
but when you're dealing
with crypto algorithms,
I've learned to
just leave them be.
So instead, it made
a lot more sense
for our team to simply
upgrade their GCF
instances to use more RAM.
Now, as listed in
the documentation,
RAM provisions are connected to
higher performing CPUs, which,
based our tests, could more
effectively crunch the crypto
numbers and, hopefully,
bring down costs.
To figure out if
this would help us,
we set up a simple test by
deploying a sample crypto
code set and flooded it with
requests over five minutes.
For our 512meg
instances, we capped out
at about 25
invocations a second,
taking around 60k milliseconds
per each response.
However, when we
moved to 2 gigabytes,
we ended up with 35
invocations a second,
and our response time capped
out at around 15k milliseconds.
Now after seeing our
tests, our crypto friends
threw more CPU power
at their problem
and brought their response
times down significantly.
To learn more about
some of the code
we saw today, check
out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas
content set because, when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]